Chrysler and Bobby Lee just discovered
their agents have been secretly
sabotaging any opportunities between the
two of them for the last 15 years now
commonly referred to by comedy fans as
the thermostat beef Bert and Bobby's
agents have been better Rivals ever
since 2008 when they shared an office
space together and would constantly
argue about the temperature of the room
because of this both agents have been
shutting down any opportunities
involving comedians represented by the
other causing Bobby Lee Andrew Schultz
and Tim Dylan to miss out on attending
Bert kreischer's fully loaded Festival
one of the biggest comedy events of the
Year this behind the scenes beef has
allegedly been going on for years now
which is why it's so crazy